as as the amount of
of immunity develops in the population
so each
future wave
becomes less of a problem for government
so
this year this january we are in a much
better position
than we were last january
yeah
we we haven't had a lock down and we
haven't seen the same number of deaths
you know seen a similar number of
hospitalizations but but a few far fewer
deaths than we have and we haven't gone
into a full lockdown
so so
so this january has been much better
than last january and i expect that next
january
will be better than this january
yeah
and on average that trend will continue
so that each year is going to get better
however
i think the other thing that we can be
pretty sure about is that there will be
steps backwards certainly with
new medications coming through
we know the vaccines have worked and are
working well
we know that so there's lots of positive
steps here to enable us to try to as you
said coexist with covid
hopefully with omicron wave being
less
um
less severe uh that's a positive step
into what the strain is doing but of
course i i wouldn't be able to predict
that
and so we would just hope that
having as many tools as possible
will help us in the future to treat and
manage all of our patients as well as we
can
that's the most important thing here
it's about living living with covered
safety or living safely with covert and
they probably you know there will be
different perspectives on what that
safely looks like won't there um and i
think you know we have to remember that
we are still only two years into this
pandemic
and we all desperately want the pandemic
to end but we're still learning a lot
about you know
covid about the different variants about
what works and what doesn't work and
it's really really important that we
continue to gather that insight that
learning that knowledge that experience
to the last two years and turn that into
that longer term
living safely with kovid's strategy the
vaccinations uh throughout the world
have made massive impact on people's
lives um you know i'm from india and
i've seen the impact they had in india
and you know and they've done a great
job the uk have done a fantastic job so
you know it's reassuring that
you know
there are people out there doing such a
fantastic job uh using these
vaccinations these drugs in such a short
time
and and we've got a clear path going
forward